how do you guys feel about Parks just
like city parks like who doesn't like
Park like in general yeah just just like
as as in as a place to go to you know
waste an afternoon or something like
that well for as an adult as an adult
and a kid well as an adult I think it's
fine every now and then you know across
yeah especially in Tokyo because you
[ __ ] need it yeah you don't see grass
otherwise you you gotta go you're like
every once in a while bro or otherwise
you fill up that camera yeah you're
never gonna see anything like London has
so much [ __ ] parks and like lovely
scenery and like Tokyo is like how about
one park but you have to pay to get in
yeah yeah you're prepared to get in yeah
or yogi park where everyone on Earth in
Japan goes to and it's like yeah this is
[ __ ] yeah yeah I don't know like because
I've I've been why do you have a hot
take on Parks I just saw I like I don't
know if it's just parks in Japan or or
anything like that I just don't like
them like
I just like for me like for me wait wait
did you like parks in the UK
not really why not what'd you do in them
just walk it's not like a cinema it's
not like there's something to do just
walk you enjoy it you got to make your
own fun
you're like terminally online
what do you mean what do you do you just
go to the park you chill out you walk
you breathe in do you like walking
walking's fine but I can walk anywhere
can't the type of [ __ ] walk
outside being like what's the quest
that's
me right like my favorite Parks right my
favorite parks for example is if there's
like an activity to do at the park
around or something uh you know maybe if
I would come when I go on a playground
no no I don't know because
sometimes
the reason I bring this up and it's this
this is why I'm like married to cities
because we have exactly the same
opinions we we we started like walking
around which we explore like we explore
like part of our neighborhood and
there's a park that we've never been to
yeah and we're like oh maybe we should
explore the park that's what that's what
people do on this case right that's what
humans act like right on on days we uh
like an alien they're just landed on uh
it's like humans doing this thing called
Walking In the Park yeah yeah yeah so we
try it out so we go in the spark and you
have to pay to get in this park so we're
like okay it must be a pretty big Park
which one uh I don't remember the park
name it's it's near to where I live so I
don't really want a dog to myself yeah
um but clearly he doesn't care there's
not a lot of Park since when you have to
pay yeah only the big ones yeah uh so we
paid to get in and we've paid to get
into Parts before normally what we like
to do is we like to cycle around the
park there's normally like it's normally
big enough to have like us like a bike
rental and we just cycle around that to
me is like Japan yeah in Japan is there
I don't know there isn't anywhere near
where I live I remember I remember there
was one pretty famous one that's massive
but thank you I'm not sure if it's in
Tokyo or saitama I'll have to double
check but it's not it's definitely not
in like the center Center but you know
that's that's the kind of Park
experience I liked
um sure maybe I'll just say walking
right because me and Sydney it sounds
like you hate walking me and me and
Sydney are just walking around and being
like where's the fun when does the fun
start so you just take it in you breathe
you know it's like good for you to look
at green
that
we had this we had this moment where we
were just like walking around uh we were
just walking around and we were just
like you know she was just like walking
around like asking us like uh why do
people go to pogs just like just like
asking each other why do people enjoy
parks and everything like that and then
and then we walked we walk past and
there was there was this one kid just
having the [ __ ] time of his life just
like
like collecting leaves and [ __ ] just
like jumping in them yeah like
collecting them again oh yeah and we
were just like [ __ ] that kid I wish I
was that kid [ __ ] no because kids below
like eight can entertain themselves with
anything yeah they have fun with their
imagination
this is the bonus yeah I was like good
God damn it I wish I was having that
much fun no dude bro that's so nice just
chilling just walking around a block and
just you know having like that 20
minutes are just just nothing yeah there
was just some days where I'm just like I
don't have it often uh because I'm a lot
like where I'm like the majority of the
time when I go outside I'm I'm there to
fulfill a quest but like sometimes some
days man you just wake up or you're
doing some [ __ ] and you're just like
[ __ ] I just need to get out yeah you you
just grab you grab a coffee yeah you
just go out on the park just walk out of
your house just go in a random direction
for like it doesn't even have to be long
10 15 minutes and that just refreshes
your mind it's so nice no I I I get that
because like to me so it so why don't
you just do that but do it in a park
like why are you expecting like a
[ __ ] QuickTime event or something
because because like okay okay we're
waiting for that one NPC
what are you hoping what did you expect
the park to be I don't know it just
feels it just it's always felt weird for
me you know having to go to a place to
feel happy okay I I I love I love like
the feeling you guys are talking about
but like yeah so to me like that's
that's
spontaneous you know that's that's
spontaneous I love for example also
you're asking why people go to the park
on routine
yeah as it's is it for like is it for
the environment there's a lot of studies
been done but like just being around
like nature or seeing a lot of like
green nature yeah uh is just generally
quite healthy and it's kind of there's
so many studies on it but and again I
don't know any top of my head but it's
very relaxing it's good for you yeah uh
and you should do it yeah that's why I I
used to love in Australia I used to love
going on like bushwalks yeah like you
know just like through the rainbow it's
relaxing no no I love that because like
and it's like it's not exciting and
every direction you look it's just trees
but it's nice I do it
um not semi-regularly like every few
weeks I go to the park just walk yeah
yeah like because for me I think I think
what's always like weird not weirded me
out but one one thing that I I've never
like got Parks like personally is just
because it always felt like so
artificial you know in terms of like I
love the feeling of waking up and just
exploring nature and anything like that
and that's why I really value it on like
trips where we go to somewhere where it
is an actual like you know beautiful
place yes where you just can wake up go
to the countryside and you just get that
kind of feeling Parkers have always been
like I go there and I never
ever I never ever get that feeling of
the same Tranquility it's just like oh
this is if I walk for like 10-15 minutes
I'm gonna reach the end and go back to
City I mean it's just like obviously in
like parks and mainly for cities right
where it's just so much concrete yeah
drab gray yeah it's to I mean it is
you're more livable that's why like you
know
Japan had figured out they were like oh
wait we should probably should have
built more trees in our cities because
the newer parts of Tokyo all have trees
yes everywhere yeah because you realize
like subconsciously in your brain you're
like oh this is so much nicer because
there's nature with the concrete yeah
you know it does something in your brain
where you just feel like oh this is more
pleasant yeah that's why I in my opinion
some of the best cities I've been to are
the ones that are built around the
nature that is or it's built within the
nature not so much like Tokyo where it's
like let's just take all the nature away
replace with buildings yes and then
maybe every now and every [ __ ] 10 20
meters we'll plan one skinny ass I think
the most parks to City ratio I think
yeah it could be wrong you could check
that Kai yeah and I think this comes
back to when I was a kid because I I
always it always weirded me out as a kid
where it was just like the concept of
just plopping in Greenery in like a
concrete jungle I don't mean I get an
hour as an adult to be like you know you
need a change of environment or
something like that yeah but I just like
to me as a kid it was I I never I never
went to a park for that if I was going
to a park I was playing footy I was
going to the playground activity and as
an adult I still mentally like I link up
I link parks to like the same kind of
mental barrier where it needs to be
going there for a singular activity I
mean there's nothing wrong with this
with in your age to want to go to the
park to play footy with your mates oh no
in my opinion but also yeah it's
important for cities to have communal
spaces yes of course in Tokyo where the
[ __ ] can you go yeah it's like an open
space
like nothing nothing you have to go
outside it's like yeah Tokyo is like you
know you can't do anything you have to
go towards like [ __ ] uh mitaka like
yeah you know it's it's good to have
options yes
London has a [ __ ] ton of parks it's
pretty nice why did I not see a single
Park in London because you're in Central
Central honestly but even then Central
London has a lot of parks
oh I saw one Park actually yeah you're
probably walking on the touristy spots
and the biggest one is Hyde Park
obviously that's very touristy yeah but
you know even where like yeah I mean I
lived in London there was London parks
are like [ __ ] massive to the point to
the point where you forget that it's a
park right right I think that's also
played into the fact that there are a
lot of like small parks in Tokyo as well
yes but it's just I'm just like this
ain't a park this is a patch of grass
because there's some trees in it oh this
is the park there's two football pitches
a pond and a bunch of other [ __ ] yeah
yeah enough space you can do whatever
you want like yeah it's valued a lot
more I think in oh definitely Europe and
so well not that it was valued a lot
more I think it just wasn't in the city
planning when Tokyo was being developed
like it was not all about developing
space for commercial use yeah yeah and
they were like oh [ __ ] just trying to
build as much infrastructure in a small
amount of space as possible right yeah
yeah but then obviously now we figured
out that hey if you build a city with
more trees and more green that people
are happier yeah like I think it is like
there is a correlation between how happy
absolutely and how yeah yeah how much uh
nature there is there or accessible I
guess in Tokyo it's like everyone's like
I don't want you to leave Tokyo well
that's such a [ __ ] that's why like I
could never live in like Central Tokyo
and that's why I don't live in central
Tokyo because it's like every time I go
to Central Tokyo I'm like this is drab
as [ __ ] like there's no Greenery like I
and again as someone who grew up next to
a [ __ ] National Park if I don't see
even a little bit of greenery I just
Panic oh you've seen Wales [ __ ]
nothing yeah exactly Fields I like it
but that's it yeah that's what you want
that's what you want yeah even living in
Brighton I would love to take drives
like down to like the South Downs and
everything like that you know just just
get like I don't know to to me that is
what an escape is you know I it to me
it's like a commitment to get into like
a proper environment to reset myself and
I really really like that so so if you
and Sydney don't like Parks what do you
do sorry so if you you and Sydney don't
like Parks or like don't like walking
through Parks what is like the
equivalent that you guys do I know we
just have light in nature yeah so how do
we see nature yeah how do you experience
it I mean normally we just through my 4K
TV I mean normally we just take like a
weekend trip outside of Tokyo or if we
have a date that we normally have an
activity we're doing on that date the
activity isn't going to a park the
activity if we go to a park the activity
is going to a park to do X or to do y or
to cycle around if that makes sense
right to me like it's it's gonna sound
weird but just walking to me I don't
really count that as an activity it's
just a thing that I do I'm not walking
if I'm walking I need a destination to
walk to okay I can't just be walking for
the sake of walking no I don't know if
that makes any sense I like walking for
the second walking I I get uh I get gone
in that sense like I also like I'm I'm
stuck I'm slowly starting to get better
at it because Aki is definitely the type
of person who just wants to like walk
with no destination yeah and I'm like
yeah that's fun when I do it with you
but not when I'm by myself
then I'm just like well [ __ ] I'm just
wasting time at this point like I would
be doing something else at this time
even though I know in my head this is
good for me yeah right and it's and it's
a good escape from all the other [ __ ]
I'm doing but I think again I'm just
like perpetually just bound to my work
in that sense where I'm trying to escape
and yet in my head I'm just like
be answering emails right now yeah I
don't know I know sometimes it's about
the journey not the destination but
always about the journey it is always
about the Journey of the destination but
sometimes I need that destination to
make me appreciate the journey just just
to just so I can have that mental that
mental thing of just okay I know where
I'm going and then I could just you know
zone out and just appreciate the journey
I appreciate that a lot of people are
just like I'm just going to do whatever
and uh we'll find out what the
destination is along the way uh I cannot
do that [ __ ] [ __ ] give me a
destination give give me an end point
give me a goal to work towards even if
it's just like the most Bare Bones like
simple goal yeah and that would just
like allow me to like just just tell me
I need to like go to a [ __ ] Family
Mart yeah it's better it's better I know
there's one around the corner but I'm
like you know what I'll skip that one go
to the next one yeah yeah to make the
journey worth it even that is fine look
you can you can put me here and the
destination here and go this [ __ ]
route and I'll be like okay let's go
that route but if you just if you just
tell me oh let's just go up here and
just see where we go I'm like no give me
a destiny just tell me where we go tell
me where we're ending up is it a family
more is it are we going for the are we
going for the family chicken just just
let me know I don't know yeah I guess
it's strange I guess I don't really mind
because in my head I'm like oh it's just
a form of light exercise yeah right so
I'm like oh that's fine then um you know
I'm just like if in my head if it's
exercise I'm like oh yeah cool no no and
like you know I see it that way as well
but again it's like I I'm more
determined to go through that exercise
if I knew where I was going yeah and
it's like and it could be like super
[ __ ] fast super short it doesn't
matter just the fact that I have a goal
to reach makes me work for the goal and
it makes it worth working towards the
goal yeah I think I also just I think
the reason why I like IRL streaming as
well is that I can kind of pseudo
exercise while doing it just walking
around all the time yeah you just
content machine you know I want to make
content but I want to min max everything
yeah I also I just like the fact that I
can
just do great content and be some
somewhat active at the same time yeah
yeah it's kind of nice as well sure
because it's like oh okay I don't feel
like such a slob and I can go home and
relax and I feel like oh that was not
bad I was good yeah but then when you
get home and you're like [ __ ] I have to
make contact although I know yeah
although I normally drink when I do IRL
so I cancel anything